[Applaus]
oder fragt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
morgen kann
ja
[Musik]
o
warum
[Musik]
matthias sempach ist ein könig ein
schwingerkönig
diesen titel dürfen nur die sieger vom
eidgenössischen schwingfest tragen
was er mit zehn jahre verschwinden aber
dank zum schwingen - oder sie wird dort
nur sehr bekannter kampf morgan glaubt
stoff austria übernehmen ist zeitraum
tragen deswegen nicht
der in gang gebracht
[Musik]
sempach hat den königstitel 2013 in
burgdorf erzwungen
schwingerkönig bleibt man für die
ewigkeit
es gibt keine ex schwingerkönige
übernehmender schulden verstaatlicht
aussieht wenn sie auch gut springen und
ich zögerte verteidiger des strohs das
ist ja der eindruck ling
[Musik]
es ist ein ungeschriebenes gesetz in
schwinger kreisen dass auch ein
schwingerkönig einer bürgerlichen arbeit
nachgeht
selbst wenn er vom sponsoring leben
könnte womöglich eher gering für eine
gedrückte jahrzehnten über landschaft
dort sind bis zu bedanken
der gelernte metzger und bauer ist
derzeit angestellter und an zwei tagen
in der woche als futtermittel vertreter
unterwegs ich muss morgen mit der
leistung das wird auch wie später sport
manchmal vitamine ein kleines
leistungsloch und bitte dafür dass ich
genau zumal die arbeiter so gut
[Musik]
und da ist es ganz schön auf eine menge
strom mit einer autogrammstunde user
bevorzugen als einer der wenigen hat er
den sieger moni behalten immerhin
dagegen wert eines kleinwagens in
schweden fest
die la brisa marschieren
es ist tradition und dieses mal stellt
die start- und sie dankten für die hat
deswegen schon venture monique wind
[Musik]
es ist tradition ein jahr vor den
eidgenössischen die zehn lebend preise
kühe und pferde dem publikum vorzuführen
so wie hier in ste im august 2015
[Musik]
der zukünftige sieger monier zum ersten
mal gezeigt flankiert von seinem götti
den freiburger eck schwinger hans peter
pellet
[Musik]
ein jahr vor den eidgenössischen tritt
auch die direktorin auf
[Musik]
die ehemalige juristin gehört zusammen
mit den obligaten ehrendamen zu den
wenigen frauen unter den funktionären
vom könig wird erwartet dass er an
solchen veranstaltungen hoch hält
muss lukas topfit jetzt keine
flüchtlinge aber der bisher positiv
zusätzlich drei monate vorher am
oberaargauischen schwingfest passierte
es der könig stürzte und holte sich
komplizierte brüche am fußgelenk nach
der operation war es aus mit schwingen
es ist september 2015 und der könig
hofft dass sein arzt ihm heute das
training wieder erlaubt alles andere
wäre eine katastrophe für ihn
[Musik]
hei de ist seit neun jahren mit simbach
zusammen zum heiraten war noch keine
zeit sagt er
der gemeinsame sohn henry ist neun
monate alt und da irgendwelche gespräche
bislang nämlich see und ein böses
gesehen sind wieder ins gespräch und
dennoch verlängert
der vorstand musste ja spitze auf dem
flughafen bayern wird gebaut für den
grössten sportanlass der schweiz eine
arena für 52.000 menschen 25 millionen
sind budgetiert und man wählen natürlich
gewinn machen viel zu groß sei der
anlass kritisierten viele schon in
burgdorf und auch jetzt wieder
die rektorin isabel emmenecker wusste
bislang wenig vom schwingen ist aber
seit vier jahren mit viel herzblut im
amt funktioniert und ja positiv und
höhnisch der kriegt ihr sempach kommt
gerne frühzeitig auf den schwing platz
weil er um die kraft mentale
vorbereitung weiß
[Musik]
aber das macht ja schon länger
eingeschlossen
danke danke
[Musik]
das wissen wir jetzt mache ich sehr oft
machen sie vorher dran
[Musik]
männer schwingen seit hunderten von
jahren
die mädchen und frauen offiziell seit
[Musik]
das erster schwinger museum ist ihr
verdienst ihren bodenmann million ihr
vater schwinger legende karl meli hat
bis heute als einziger neuen
eidgenössische grenze gewonnen
der zweifache schwingerkönig war total
dagegen dass seine tochter auch schwingt
[Applaus]
geprüft
das ist wirklich das ist vielleicht das
im normalfall mit 34 jahren hat sie dann
über sich selbst gesiegt und doch noch
angefangen auch im sägemehl zu kämpfen
[Applaus]
das kommt bestimmt
die erfolgreichste schwimmerin heute ist
die 31-jährige sekundarlehrerin auch bei
den frauen gilt wer zuerst auf dem
rücken liegt hat verloren
[Applaus]
beschwingt nicht zu befürchten
was bei den einander moni ist bei den
frauen ein pferd aber auch die
königinnen nehmen in der regel lieber
den gegenwert in schweizer franken
die unterschiede sind sonst eher
äußerlich ja ich glaube dass man
deswegen der staat für verkauft steht
politisch oft viel herzblut und einfach
mit freude damit sport
[Musik]
herbst im emmental und der
schwingerkönig verlässt sein
hoheitsgebiet mit sohn henry und
freundin heidi besuchte er seinen nach
frankreich ausgewanderten lieblingsonkel
sammeln der hat dort einen großen
bauernhof übernommen
[Musik]
runde eingezogen
da hatte ich hier jetzt unter nicht dass
ich eine idee aber vom mann josef
schwung und sandbacher schweden 0 2
[Musik]
schweiz gleich gewusst eigentlich
widerruf stahl und wo es aber eigentlich
auch die zahlen lägen auf
würde die story ist noch bei troisdorf
hätte die abstimmung klar wird dass ich
das auch konkurrenziert ja relativ mehr
außer der maschinen haushalt bis
sechsjährigen bruder und der
kindergarten ist die freie minute im
stau
das schau mir das stück sie aber also
sechs jahre alt war mussten seine eltern
die pacht aufgeben und alle kühe
verkaufen
also danke das von ihr schaltet ein
aromastoff china basiert jetzt zeugen
der englische hof zu erholen
wo mir spaß macht momentan haiti seit
den anfängen als die kirche da schwingen
zeitweise verboten hatte und seit den
60er jahren als langhaarige noch aus dem
verband ausgeschlossen wurden hat sich
einiges verändert
die heja wahnsinnig hohe strafe unter
das hätte natürlich auch sein motto wenn
ihr beim eigentlich sogar in jedem
erhöht durch minister scharf und
natürlich auch erreicht dass bereich
genossen france gewinnt haben eine
eigene wege natürlich wohnen und
popularität gebracht
hübsch occean athlet so brillant ist
natürlich alle anderen
es geht nicht um daraus aber der mädchen
etwas gefangen
[Applaus]
ein vorbild das möchte simbach auch sein
darum erscheint auch vorbildlich an
anlässen und stellt sich den medien
so erwarten es die sponsoren
aber er hat auch grenzen
ja
man bekommt also durchaus vom sponsor
was heißt das
ich galt
[Musik]
hans peter pellet war bis vor kurzem der
schwinger mit den meisten grenzen die je
ein schwinger gewonnen hat 136
[Musik]
als jugendlicher hat sempach mit ihm
trainiert ein harter kern sei er der
pellet dieser hat mit 40 die schwinger
hosen an den nagel gehängt
es wäre als hätte er seine seele
verkauft wenn er sponsoren gehabt hätte
sagte er
[Musik]
also was wir vorhaben ist bei ihnen vor
der show king hat allerdings das
eigentlich beruflich man muss sehr
geschockt
[Musik]
der schmerz größer sponsor hätte und auf
dem buckel
für sie war strom solle die bereits das
ist dass der sport und so dass das wird
länger sie mehr um
[Musik]
das erste training im schwingkeller für
matthias sempach nach der verletzung
nur da ist auch von gästen die sich
schon zu brauchen so gut lief es ähnlich
gut dotiert erste wirkt weiter zieht das
defizit und das ist vor allem dass hier
immer gut was da vor ihnen hiermit beruf
suchen und buchen auf dem kaffeetisch
das heutige nominierung lina so
wichtiger da passiert nach drei guten
morgen
sonntag das training kostet uns und der
marke machen und einzigartig und der
zehn jahre jüngere teamkollege renault
käse ist einer der ihn gefährlich werden
könnte für mich sehr wichtig
[Musik]
fürs eidgenössische werden alle drei
jahre 100 paar neue schwinge hosen
genäht
schwinger steigen nicht in die eigenen
hosen
sie fassen diese auf dem platz da hängen
ja noch ein paar chancen gut dass man so
wenig neid hinzu für sie dass das leid
das lange währen nun hier raus hat hier
noch nie passiert oder wer sie wie es
hier nach dem besitzer nicht der achte
betrachte dann die auf der suche sind
des ganges dazu rückt also der häuser
logo ausgang soll wieder so machen
das wird gerade der sportchef des
eidgenössischen holt die hosen
persönlichkeit in den verschiedenen
schwingklubs müssen diese nun ein
geschwungen werden
seit einigen jahren gibt es auch dunkle
hosen eine konzession ans publikum damit
die schwinger gut unterschieden werden
können
diese änderung erforderte viel
überzeugungsarbeit den schwingerverband
der verband wacht darüber dass die
schwinger arena werbefrei bleibt an der
letzten versammlung hat sich der
seeholzer otto zu wort gemeldet weil
ihnen gewisse veränderungen auf dem
springplatz sorgen bereiten
doch die gott was nicht seinen mit ein
paar kästen grand hotel geht meinen
angetan ist ganz klar umgang mit den
tagen davor natürlich spieler sondern
mindestens zwei wenn man gewonnen hat
geht momentan hilft muss oder ein server
steht obwohl sie schon ab
das ist die story zum täglich und afrika
ab - nicht ohne pumpe und ganz platz und
trägt jetzt ein großer starker bedarf
keiner früh jetzt das vertrauen das ist
okay und dann muss nicht zwingend das
ist für eine so junge kinder folglich
nimmt wunderschönes jungschwinger 25 mal
verloren hätte das wäre jetzt nie im
spiel auf die tribüne aber ist für den
erfolg der emotionen muss kontrolliert
ich sage so körper malige ich von mir
aus gesehen das sagt etwas das zum
schwingen und wetter bis der fehler
machen und geschminkt wurde das ist die
aktive dass man sich überzeugen dass
körperbemalung eigentlich nicht die
grabplatte tradition aus
der böse ist ein appenzeller hier in
gais lebt michael bless ein
erfolgreicher nordostschweizer schwingen
er hat lieber schlangen als kühe und
seine tattoos seien für ihn eine art
tagebuch
[Musik]
wie einfach der meinung dass tattoos mit
tradition vom schwimmsport kaputt machen
sondern über traditionen wie pfleger vom
schwimmsport ich habe andere interessen
im privatleben der dazugehörige tattoos
und definition nicht dass der
schwimmsport und tattoos da irgendjemand
im weg standen
dass zwischen diesen blöden sprüchen von
meinen kollegen so dastehen und rüber
und die schnitten sie ist dafür schon
ich wohl kommen
viel wichtiger ist ihm ein ganz speziell
an sieg
da ist vom eidgenössischen in frauenfeld
do 7 2 und im dritten gang der natur
center können und dass familie natürlich
sehr spezielles top-favoritin schwiegen
fest und natürlich auch bekanntheit und
die vision ja nicht bekannt standard
auch sie und hat mich beflügelt hat dem
tag und auch noch einmal wie die mini
schwimmkarriere jetzt zehn vor dem gang
unterzeichneten aufruf dass sie von
jemand den magen sondern einfach nur
fragen schwingen
sie hat auch vor niemandem angst
die neuseeländische mehrfache
weltmeisterin im kugelstossen valerie
adams trainiert regelmäßig mit simbach
in magglingen in fast
sehr oft nach erstellt hat und die hoffe
dass wir geben also fahren sie ich
glaube er braucht es vertrauen braucht
aber christi
wie viele athleten aufmerksamkeit muss
emotional beeinflusst werden nicht nur
rational und ich glaube bin praktisch
das ist das auch richtig auf emails das
nicht unbedingt immer verursacher sich
vorstellen
[Musik]
die mit
nachwuchs in einem der ältesten
schwingklubs der schweiz mitten in der
stadt zürich
karl meli trainierte ab und zu hier
seine tochter ihren hat hier die
nachwuchs mädchen für sägemehl fit
gemacht
zwei und zwei zusammen jeder überall
entweder stich für stich oder stehen
sehen
[Applaus]
der könig hat einen harten kampf vor
sich genau vor einem jahr verletzte er
sich an diesem schwimmfest und muss die
saison vorzeitig beenden
und heute hat er eine angerissene rippen
spitzenschwinger wie stucki oder wenger
sind allerdings verletzt oder krank
gemeldet
[Applaus]
gelesen
dollar
[Applaus]
über sein hobby auch die eltern simbach
sind bei jedem kampf meines sohnes auf
dem platz
aber irgendwie interesse und das
schwingen wieder schafft zum schwingen
und sie sind warten unterscheidet sie
das
[Musik]
naja aber mit denen 21 geübt wird
irgendwann die behaupten dass david
geführt und ausland und nanni denn die
junge schwimmerin hosanna die
telefonnummer von schnee einfach
behauptet dass der junge noch besser sei
sehr schwierig das erste leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der sohn schwenkt am oberaargauischen
oben auf und geht als sieger vom platz
er schwingt so gut dass ihm ein
gestellter das heißt ein unentschieden
für den sieg gereicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den sieger moni nimmt er nicht lieber
das kuvert mit dem geld aber ein foto
muss sein wegen der erinnerung für
stuben buffet
[Musik]
ja
[Gelächter]
keine bleibt
mehr
ja
schade
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
außen schwing platz kernen riad der
könig hat besuch aus der stadt
[Musik]
sohn henry ist inzwischen eineinhalb
jahre alt und hat bereits eine eigene
schlinger hose von paul ekman
wichtige steuern ist wird nachgeschaut
was zeit kostet
ja und jetzt ist sie stabil
[Applaus]
jonas september bis 2
drei jahres kurz bu momentan noch nicht
so recht groß und sollte und der
tourismus verbessere
sie machen es gut sechs wochen vor dem
eidgenössischen das regiewerk schwingen
in der innerschweiz
5000 zuschauerinnen und zuschauer kommen
mit der bahn auf den autofreien berg
darunter auch das siegerland daisy
deutschland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war die antwort fiel der dow
[Musik]
blogger der morgen das ist echt
gefälscht und steht unter dampf mit
großem applaus auf dem platz zwei
gekommen
[Applaus]
ich mag
meine mutter hatte zugelassen
ich glaube das es gibt
[Musik]
noch zwei wochen bis zum grössten
sportanlass der schweiz die
infrastruktur für 250.000 menschen steht
bereit
die direktorin schläft im büro auf dem
gelände weil sie noch sehr viele fragen
beantworten muss die lebend kreise
warten bereits auf die schwinger und das
publikum im sogenannten gabentempel sind
preise im wert von rund einer million
ausgestellt und die direktorin zieht
eine erste bilanz
sie wäre damit der sport es geht da
nicht um geld und macht und west
gottwals und transfersummen und so und
das ist glaubt schöne dass die schwimm
sport immer noch die waage halten was
ist schon im akh obwohl es jetzt für
populäre tisch und für medien springen
wollte und das steuersystem das
bedrucken und der könig
der tut was er immer tut vor einem kampf
in ein paar tagen wird matthias sempach
hier gegen andere könige und solche die
es werden wollen in die hosen steigen
[Musik]
wie aber wirkt so bezahlt werden sollen
in ein offener umgang vergangen gewinnt
der verein rücklagen
[Musik]
ja